the thing about civilization is
it keeps you civil you get rid of one
you can't count on the other
people are tribal the more settled
things are the bigger the tribes can be
the churn comes and the tribes get small
again right now
you and i are a tribe of two hey guys
pete here
no excerpt to open the video today
because most of my favorite lines from
the episode were lifted straight from
the books
this is my breakdown for the expanse
season 5 episode 6 and it will contain
spoilers for everything that's happened
in the tv series up to this point as
someone who's read the books i'll be
referring to them but i won't give away
spoilers about future events
and so now let's get to it we opened the
episode looking in on abasarala on luna
she looks broken up about what happened
and the fact that she can't reach her
husband
is definitely weighing on her while
she's trying to call arjun
we meet the new secretary general and i
gotta say
he doesn't exactly exude confidence
i'm gonna throw out a prediction that
this guy might not be the right guy for
the job
we learned that david pastner was the
minister
of transportation which kind of gives
you the feeling that a lot of people in
the government must have
died for him to be in charge he's out of
his depth and we see that he understands
this as he explains to abasara how he
got where he
is and he does ask her to join his
cabinet and that seems like a solid
decision
we get hints that things are pretty bad
at least in new york where he was
he says that he saw half a midtown
underwater and we do learn that her
daughter and grandchildren survived
so that's where we leave things with her
she's really worried about arjun but
duty calls
and she has other things she has to deal
with at tycho
the rossi is now set to take off bull
and holden and the new crew were able to
locate and remove the code that sakai
used to compromise it
monica stewart shows up she wants to go
along for the ride bull doesn't like
this idea and it's a pretty funny
exchange when he asked her if she's
experienced high g maneuvers
and she points out that yeah you know on
this ship actually
when we were the first people to survive
passing through the ring gate
we don't learn much here except for that
they're going to be chasing after the
zamiya
and we do see that holden has one unread
saved message from naomi
from the chet's mocha that's titled if
something goes wrong but we don't see
him
open it in my preview discussion video
about this episode i discussed how the
razorback could be a sitting duck
temporarily while it restarted its drive
and we do see them get boarded here by
the belter ship that was pursuing them
this sets up a nifty little action
sequence and we get ourselves some
martian marine power
armor porn at this point in the story it
should have been a while since bobby put
a suit on
and i enjoyed where after she cut
through everyone we get this shot of her
smiling
as she's back in her element doing what
she's best at
she handles the borders with no problem
one is able to make it back to the ship
and that sets her up to test the limits
of the suit as she tries to hold back
the retractable gate
while she was engaging with them alex
was able to make his way over and put an
explosive charge
on the ship so when they took off it
detonated bobby and alex were able to
start the drive back up on the razorback
and get away
and that's where we leave them for this
episode on the pela marco's pissed that
naomi
got her message out and the rascanante
is safe
he has a meltdown where sin apologizes
for letting her near the calms
and philip apologizes for bringing her
onto the ship in the first place
he tells him the spacer and then sin
gets in his face and tells him to do it
himself
in front of everybody on the bridge of
his ship it's good to build up the
tension
and he does put philip in a difficult
situation with crazy stakes he asked him
if he was in charge if he would space
his own mother
philip says he would spare her life and
we'll have to see how this goes
i'll talk about this a little bit more
after i finish the recap since it feels
like things are turning in a direction i
wasn't expecting
philip goes to see naomi and i guess
it's confirmed that both
him and marco knew that she tried to
kill him with a knife which i didn't
think was the case but i guess that's
what happened
through his reaction she figures out
that the ross ante is okay
and she tries to use the opportunity to
get philip to understand how his
father's using him
she says he wouldn't die for you but he
would let you die for him
that he made you a murderer and at some
point the gravity of what you've done is
gonna hit you
she's speaking from experience but at
this point he doesn't want to hear it
we check in with drummer and we see one
of her husbands and one of her wives
coupling and oxana asks joseph if he's
worried about
kamina so we get a little bit of insight
into how this polyamorous
marriage works how they're sharing their
concerns joseph says he is worried about
drummer because the deaths of fred and
ashford are still recent but more than
that he's worried about the family
we see marco arrive with his fleet
drummer and her people are surprised to
see that they're arriving in martian
ships
this means they have no way to run away
or fight they're gonna have to go over
and meet with them when they go to the
pella there's a lot going on
they see members of different belter
factions on his ship drummer realizes
when she sees people from black sky and
golden bow
that this is tribute they're trading off
crew members between the factions
as a deterrent for the groups turning on
each other they realize that if these
groups are already on his side that he's
got a lot of belters behind him
the conversation between drummer and
marco is fantastic
and is on the level of what we saw with
sin talking to naomi about the belter's
plight in the last episode
she airs her grievances about him
starting this war in the first place
about him killing ashford and fred
johnson
and from the position he's in it's
pretty easy for him to put all those
things to the side
the reality is is that there is a war
going on now and if her and her family
don't join him they're essentially
against them
joseph asked about food pointing out
that earth is the only source for live
soil
and complex biologicals this gives marco
a chance to show that his planning has
gone beyond just throwing some rocks at
earth as far as we can tell this is
something that he's anticipated
he's working with people from ganymede
and that gives him more credibility
and while that goes a long way what
really sways drummer's group when they
go back to their ship to discuss it is
that he's created a situation where
there really isn't a choice
earth will declare war against the belt
and the only way they can survive is if
they join together
and for all his shortcomings this is the
thing that marco understood
that when they have to fight for their
own survival enough of these factions
will come together as one nation to
fight
drummer goes back to tell marco they'll
join they exchange her husband serge
for coral which is kind of interesting
because she seems to be his most loyal
follower at this point and it's also
interesting because she said
if you want to kill naomi just ask me
next time and then he sent her away
in this meeting he introduces drummer to
philip and talk turns to how she was
good friends with his mother naomi
and he basically gives away that she's
on the ship
so where things end with drummer her and
her family have joined the free navy
they have coral on their ship and she
knows that naomi's held captive on the
pela
we see drummer and philip share a long
look then we see the free navy take off
and then philip goes to see his mother
in her cell and ask her about what
happened on the behemoth
marco's watching this on a monitor and
then he pulls up a display of his fleet
on that we see that the rasanante is
going after the zamaya
which is going in a different direction
from where they're at and that he's
planning an intercept course for the
chet's mocha
which is the ship that naomi arrived on
the remaining story from this episode
and for my money the strongest part of
it is the travels of amos and peaches
i mentioned that a lot of their dialogue
is directly from the pages of the books
and i would say they added to the
understanding we have of these two
characters and why they work together i
think the show's made more explicit what
draws amos to clarissa
at the beginning of their journey we see
that she's not doing well physically
but she's equally afraid of going back
to prison and amos points out that the
prison's not there anymore
so they probably won't try to take her
into custody they'll just shoot her
so we see that they make the decision to
go back to baltimore
while staying off the beaten path they
run into a fellow traveler
he warns them to watch out for a
specific place
a compound that has a doomsday prepper
who's really excited because yeah
doomsday came
and that this guy is taking shots at
people who approach his property we hear
amos deliver that line about
civilization that i opened the video
with
and this idea about tribes and when the
churn comes
the tribes get small again so at this
point amos
is only worried about his two-person
tribe he's officially
in churn survival mode and he knows this
prepper will have a lot of the things
that they need in order to make it to
baltimore alive
he approaches with his hands up offering
to make a trade of a water recycler
which he doesn't have
the prepper has him stripped down to
make sure he doesn't have any weapons
and then learns where amos says he left
the water recycler
and decides he doesn't need to trade him
anything for it because he can just
kill him as he's getting ready to do
that peaches activates her mods and
takes him out
and with him out of the way they're able
to go into his place
she's able to recover they warm up they
get supplies
they've got weapons they've got food and
they got some transportation with some
bikes
when she comes around he tells her not
to be afraid because he won't let
anything hurt her
he says that he heard her talking about
monsters in her sleep and she tells him
about this poem she wrote while she was
in prison
i've killed but i'm not a killer because
killers are monsters
and monsters are not afraid obviously
this means that she's afraid all the
time
and it's an interesting parallel to amos
telling
alex he hasn't been afraid since he was
5 years old when we see that hit him we
see him think about it and we see him
make that connection
she mentions how she's afraid all the
time about the things that she did
and how right it felt when she did them
and then she asked him why they went
there
because they went out of their way to
kill this guy and get his stuff because
they needed
it he says that she would have died on
the road if they hadn't done that
and that's probably true but she ties
things back to something they were
saying
before that there are ways you can live
a good life without being a good person
and going around
intending to kill people when you need
stuff really doesn't jive with that
neither peaches or amos think they are
good people but they're telling
themselves they want to try to live a
good life this makes sense to amos
because this is essentially what lydia
told him
in the flashback we saw in episode 2.
and when he hears clarissa say it out
loud he says yeah that's not a move that
holden would approve of
and then the episode ends with him
saying i need to get back to my crew
so what did i think as a fan of the
characters i really enjoyed this episode
i think the amos and peaches stuff
worked really well
in relation to the major themes we
needed the crew to split up so that
naomi and amos could confront their past
and we could get a better understanding
about what makes them tick
these are things that'll pay off down
the road and considering i was a little
underwhelmed with the first part of
amos's journey i was glad that they took
the time to really explore the character
here
him realizing that he needs to get back
to his crew
is obviously crucial and as i mentioned
earlier
i think they did a pretty thorough job
of explaining why these two characters
are drawn to each other
i also like that they spent some time on
the dynamics within drummer's faction
and how their polyamorous marriage works
i realized when i was making my book
spoilers video that we don't really know
much about this arrangement on the tv
show i was definitely wondering if they
were going to join the free navy and how
that might work
if they didn't hand wave away the impact
of fred and ashford's death
overall i think they pulled that off and
they left room for internal tensions to
arise
i think it was a good idea to focus in
on these two storylines her meeting with
the free navy and amos and clarissa on
their travels
there was a lot of different things they
had to get into it did set things up in
a way though that they just sort of
added the other parts
avasarala alex and bobby and then the
holden story
to keep those characters involved there
wasn't really any movement there they
just sort of showed them to keep them in
our minds
if you think about alex and bobby or
holden they could have easily added
those to the last episode
as both of their scenes were connected
to what happened
that said i do like how they're keeping
the action ratcheted up in the bobby and
alex story
they cut a big part of what they're
doing out from the books and we're sort
of getting to the point where i don't
think they're gonna do that at
all so i guess if they're not gonna have
a lot to do it should be exciting when
we see
them we're slowly but surely seeing some
of the effects of the rocks hitting i
think the biggest thing in this episode
was when peaches was looking at what she
thought was the moon
talking about traveling there and amos
pointing out that he thinks that's the
sun
and then we also had the new secretary
general talking about what he saw on
earth
everything still looked great although i
wasn't a huge fan of the way they filmed
the
mod attack by clarissa i mean it pretty
much played out how it did in the book
you don't know that she's there
you see the guy's gonna kill amos
anyways and she swoops in at this
incredible speed and kills him
i just thought if you looked at that out
of context it didn't seem like it really
belonged in an episode of the expanse
if that makes sense the other area where
i'm not sure how i feel
is on the pella marco seems a little bit
erratic to me
and i know part of that is because i
have expectations about the character
who he is and how he operates from
reading the books and at times it seems
a little inconsistent
i can't really explain it without book
spoilers and anyway the bottom line is
that i'm waiting to see what they're
doing with them
it could definitely pay off it could all
make sense it's just throwing me off a
little bit
at this point and that extends to philip
it extends to sin standing up to him in
front of the crew
and i think it makes more sense for me
to get into that in the next video when
i do the preview discussion
because then i can sort of step back and
try to see it in relation to the big
picture
i will be working on that video next
it'll come out in a few days i don't
talk about any spoilers in those i just
talk about where
each of the characters left off and what
that's likely to mean for where they're
going i think as far as what happened in
episode six this is a good place to end
it
i'm curious to hear what you guys think
so let me know in the comments what do
you think about drummer joining the free
navy
how big of a threat do you think marco
is for the inner planets
what did you think were the best moments
in this episode and what are you most
excited to see
going forward please like this video if
you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my channel if you haven't already
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon